ich bin davon überzeugt dass Deutschland
tatsächlich einen Energiemix braucht
nicht nur die Erneuerbaren aber auch und
deshalb wird genau in dieser
regierungswoche in dieser Sitzungswoche
vor der Sommerpause auch das EEG
beschlossen wo wirklich die Erneuerbaren
den Schub bekommen Entbürokratisierung
auf dem Weg kommen aber wir brauchen
zugleich natürlich auch grundlastfähige
Energien wie Atomkraftwerke wir haben
noch drei am Netz deshalb kann ich da
der Frau Weidel nicht ganz so recht
geben es sind noch drei am Netz wie
beispielsweise Isar 2 im Niederbayern
das ist eines der modernsten und
sichersten hoch
Atomkraftwerke die wir in Deutschland
überhaupt haben ist auch sicherer wie
das so manche europäische Atomkraftwerke
und genau deshalb ist es auch notwendig
die Diskussion über Kernkraft zu führen
einer Verlängerung drei bis fünf Jahre
auch zuzustimmen und vor allem auch die
Forschung in diesem Bereich weiter
voranzutreiben weil wir wissen nicht was
in zehn Jahren in 15 Jahren in 20 Jahren
möglicherweise die Technologie sein wird
aber wissen wir sicher von der
Bundesnetzagentur dass wir auf keine
Ressource in unserem Netz verzichten
können um grundlastfähig zu sein um ein
stabiles Netz zu haben und vor allem um
Versorgungssicherheit Bezahlbarkeit und
Verfügbarkeit gewährleisten zu können
jetzt bin ich gespannt ob Robert Habeck
hier gleich anruft und sagt mensch das
war ja toll aber das war es jetzt mit
der Koalition also Sie haben ja ein
Problem sie sind für die das
Weiterlaufen von Kernkraftwerken als FDP
als FDP-Politikerin und haben aber zwei
Koalitionspartner die das auf keinen
Fall wollen und das passiert jetzt
sicherlich also ich bin nicht die
einzige mittlerweile in der FDP es haben
sich ja zahlreiche Kolleginnen und
Kollegen schon
die Parteivorsitzende von drei bis fünf
Jahren entsprechend sich dazu bewegt ich
glaube es wir werden die um die
Diskussion nicht drumherum kommen denn
am Ende ist es die Frage wie viel Gas
wird aktuell verstromt und nachdem
Deutschland beispielsweise größere
Strommenge nach Frankreich liefert weil
dort die AKWs aktuell nicht am Netz sind
müssen wir versuchen dass wir zum
möglichst wenig Strom also aus dem
Gasbereich überhaupt verstromen und
deshalb ist es so unglaublich notwendig
auch über den Winter hinweg neben dem
sicherlich zu sensibilisieren dem
Energieverbrauch aber nicht
vorzuschreiben wie Wohnungen geheizt
werden können wie Energie verbraucht
werden können und wir haben heute erst
in der Presse verlesen können dass es
mittlerweile Vermieter gibt die
entscheiden wann es Warmwasser gibt und
wann es keines gibt all das ist
natürlich notwendig aber diese Regierung
hat sich ausgezeichnet in den letzten
Wochen doch pragmatisches und schnelles
Handeln gerade aber das ist ziemlich
bebt auch zwischen den Parteien und auch
zwischen den Vorsitzenden ich würde mal
sagen es ist allgemein so dass die Ampel
sicherlich ein Regierungsbündnis ist wo
verschiedene Meinungen oder
zusammenkommt es war keine Liebesheirat
aber wir haben tragen jetzt
Verantwortung für unser Land wir haben
Corona bekommen wir haben den Krieg in
der Ukraine angezettelt vom Putin
bekommen und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
messen die Ampel jetzt an Handlung
ganz konkret denn sie können nicht an 30
Dezember sagen so wir lassen die drei
Meile einfach jetzt doch weiter laufen
dafür brauchen sie die Brennstäbe die
müssen organisiert werden und es gibt
ein Zeitfenster was ich schließt also
das ist möglicherweise endet dieses
Monats Mitte des nächsten Monats ist
dieses Zeitfenster geschlossen das heißt
bis dahin muss eine Entscheidung fallen
richtig oder falsch also ich gebe Ihnen
da begrenzt rechnen Entscheidung muss
natürlich fallen aber es gibt
mittlerweile Betreiber ich habe dieser
zwei beispielsweise schon genannt sie
können problemlos über den Winter hinweg
uns mit Strom versorgen und dann erst in
eine reduzierte Leistung fahren
natürlich müssten die um sicherzugehen
dass wir auch im April Mai Juni nächsten
Jahres entsprechend versorgungssicher
aufgestellt sind entsprechend die jetzt
die Bestellungen machen deshalb ist es
auch so notwendig dass wir jetzt darüber
diskutieren
und ein also eine Entscheidung treffen
ob die Ampel daran scheitern wird
sagen das müssten Sie jetzt unsere
Minister Fragen und entsprechend hier
ist es mir ist es wichtig dass ich mich
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber auch
für die Unternehmen unserem Land
Einsätze und dass ich pragmatische
Vorschläge bringen sie wahrscheinlich
ein Niederlage erleben weil es bis Mitte
August bis Ende August die Rote und
Grüne wollen das nicht die ja aber die
Frage stellt sich ja nicht heute gab es
ja beispielsweise aus aus der EU ganzer
klare Aufforderung Deutschland heute
nicht mehr überlegen ob sie wollen
sondern entsprechend handeln das hat der
eu-binnenminister entsprechend auch
geäußert ganz klar Deutschland muss
handeln es gefährdet auch die Sicherheit
Europa im Bereich der Energieversorgung
deshalb glaube ich wird sich die
Situation verändern und wir sind im
Gasbereich beispielsweise an den Punkt
dass manche Turbinen gar nicht im Netz
sind warum weil man sie auch bewusst
außerhalb des Netzes aktuell hält obwohl
Firmen im Land diese Komponenten auch
liefern könnten und zwar problemlos weil
sie auf Lager legen all das müssen wir
berücksichtigen und die große Wartung im
Bereich des Gases kommt ja erst noch am
11.7 soll es soweit sein und dann ist
die Frage geht North Stream 1 wieder ans
Netz sowie geplant oder nicht und dann
stellt sich die Frage natürlich den
verstrunkten des den verstummten Anteil
an Gas kann ich dann nicht mehr aus dem
Gas nutzen wir wissen aber auch dass
unsere Nachbarn abhängig sind weil ihre
Kraftwerke aktuell die
Sicherheitsanforderungen nicht bedienen
und wie schon ein paar kurze Antwort als
Bürgerin frage ich mich wirklich wie
hoch ist denn jetzt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Regierung
diese drei Atomkraftwerke sie kriegen ja
viel mit im Bundestag nicht nur die
Minister kriegen für mit sie bekommen
auch viel mit also wie hoch ist denn die
Wahrscheinlichkeit es wird hier immer
bei 8:15 Uhr gefordert von den
Politikern übrigens von sehr vielen
lasst die Meiler laufen wie hoch ist
denn jetzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
es klappt ich würde sagen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es notwendig
wird ist hoch und die Diskussion muss
jetzt geführt werden in der Ampel aber
auch im Parlament und wir gehen jetzt
dann in den Sommerpause aber nach der
Sommerpause müssen wir diese
Entscheidung treffen verstehe dass sie
mir ausweichen es sei ihnen gestattet
ich frage jetzt mal Frau Weide wie hoch
sind sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit und vor
allem wird die Ampel dran scheitern
na gut also eigentlich sollte ja die
Ampel da überhaupt gar keine Probleme
haben weil Kernkraft wurde ja selbst von
der EU als eine grüne Energieform als
eine CO2-arme Energieform erklärt also
dementsprechend sollte da eigentlich
auch er Habeck überhaupt gar keine
Probleme damit haben die Kernkraftwerke
am Netz zu lassen die gerade
abgeschalteten die drei es waren ja da
mal irgendwie vor einigen Monaten ja
noch sechs auch wieder mit ans Netz zu
nehmen und vor allen Dingen dann eben
auch die Kernenergie weiter auszubauen
aber habex Idee und das glaube ich schon
so da kann ja eigentlich die FDP gar
nicht mitgehen seine Idee ist ja nicht
über Kernkraft zu kompensieren sondern
über Kohlekraft und Kohlekraft ist ja
nun wirklich extrem CO2 heavy sage ich
jetzt mal also dass ein grüner jetzt auf
die Idee kommt irgendwie die Kohle
Verstromung da auch mit zu verlängern
stadtkernkraft also das passt da
wirklich überhaupt gar nicht mehr so der
Sanierung jetzt noch vorbei die machen
wir es mal das ist natürlich eine Zweck
Heirat ich glaube sie haben das ja auch
eben schon so gesagt das war ja keine
Heirat so aus Liebe und Pragmatismus ich
denke mal da wird man noch sich lange
aneinander Klammern so mit all den
Widersprüchen die diese Koalition der
zweifelsohne hat und dementsprechend
bauen die Parteien ja auch ab SPD und
FDP die einzigen die davon auch
profitieren sind die Grünen Schaden weil
eben in der AFD waren auch nicht so gut
ja gut aber wir sitzen ja auch nicht in
der Regierung schade eigentlich aber wir
reden ja auch gerade über die Abendessen
das ist das was ich sagen muss das ist
nicht Politik entschuldigen Sie das ist
nicht schade wenn man sich gerade den
letzten Parteitag anschaut wenn man sich
anschaut dass ihre Partei vom
Verfassungsschutz als Verdachtsfall
eingestuft wird dass Teile ihrer Partei
beispielsweise Thüringen als
rechtsextrem rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft werden dann glaube ich muss
mal mit Fug und Recht sagen in diesen
demokratischen Land ist es eigentlich
ganz gut dass die AFD oder sogar sehr
gut dass die AFD nicht im in der
Regierung sitzt und sie kommen hier sehr
cremig und charmant R aber
ehrlicherweise sie sind Chef in einer
Partei die gespickt ist mit Nazis das
muss man immer wieder deutlich sagen
ganz klar der Name höcke ist nur einer
wenn man sich an der Basis umhört und
plötzlich heißt es der Herr Kalbitz
Rechtsextremist soll am liebsten wieder
zurück in die Partei in Teilen wird das
in ihrer diskutiert dann ist das glaube
ich etwas wo wir am Ende als
demokratisch Land froh sein können dass
ihre Partei nicht in der Regierung ist
also Schäfer ich finde das ja sehr schön
dass sie jetzt hier auch die ganze
Klaviatur des Verfassungsschutzes
spielen ein inlandsgeheimnis ein ja aber
was ist der Verfassungsschutz der
Verfassungsschutz ist ein
Inlandsgeheimdienst der von den
Regierungsparteien mit besetzt ist zu
Verunglimpfung der Opposition so und die
AFD also der Auftrag nein ehrlicherweise
habe ich bei Ihnen auch nicht gesagt und
der Verfassungsschutz ist doch überhaupt
gar keine unabhängige Behörde über die
wir jetzt reden und diesen Schuh werde
ich mir sicherlich nicht für meine
Partei anziehen welchen Schuh meinen Sie
jetzt genau den höckelschuh oder welchen
Schuh ja den Schuh den sie mir gerade
anziehen wollen das ist völlig an den
Haaren herbeigezogen
ist ach wissen Sie also Entschuldigung
reale Probleme auf der Straße die Leute
interessiert das doch überhaupt nicht
und ich werde Ihnen sagen ich werde
Ihnen eins prophezeien dieses ganze
negative framing von der AFD von der
Alternative für Deutschland wird auf
Dauer nicht durchhaltbar sein
Wahlergebnissen
wird nicht durchhaltbar sein also ja
aber das muss man aber kurzfristig
erfolgreich in ihrer Partei aber weg
aber das ist schwierig haben nirgendwo
Problemlöser und die Problemlöser sind
langfristig wir und da sind wir nicht
mehr wegzudenken daran werden Sie sich
gewöhnen müssen gleich gesagt dass die
Aussage juristisch falsch war was meinen
Sie mit juristisch falsch ja also
natürlich ist es politisches
politische Ausdrücke ist nicht
unabhängig der Verfassungsschutz ist wie
jede andere Behörde natürlich auch
insoweit nicht unabhängig als dass er
weisungsgebunden ist die große Aufgabe
und der Mehrwert des Verfassungsschutzes
in unserer Demokratie ist nicht dass er
unabhängig ist sondern dass er versucht
darauf zu achten dass nur diejenigen
Kräfte in dieser Demokratie Grip und
Halt bekommen die auch demokratisch
legitimiert sind ersten Vorstufe zur
Erklärung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
das nehme ich eine Partei dann eben
verboten gehört also das wollte ich nur
sagen insofern geht es hier nicht um
unabhängig oder nicht und die
Darstellung ist handelt sich sozusagen
um eine Behörde die von der
Regierungsparteien gesteuert ist wie
gesagt von der CDU ja aber jede Woche
eingesetzt aber sie wissen doch Fräser
ist Innenministerin also was ist denn
dann
von uns beiden hat ja nur einer Jura
studiert aber sie wissen doch auch dass
jede Behörde eingebunden ist natürlich
in den Staatsaufbau jede Behörde
das BAFA berichtet als bmwk das bmwk
kann den Barfer weil wir ja bei
Sanktionen sind Weisungen erteilen ist
das BAFA deswegen nicht unabhängig nur
die Gerichte sind unabhängig wenn Sie
den juristischen Begriff nehmen wollen
ich verstehe das ihnen das nicht passt
ist ja auch legitim dass sie politisch
sagen das passt ihnen nicht aber
juristisch ist der Verfassungsschutz
nicht so wie sie ihn beschrieben haben
aber doch er ist überhaupt nicht
ausgewogen aber gut aber lassen wir das
ist auch nicht das Thema lassen den
Verfassungsschutz gerne dass wir nicht
noch über das Bundesverfassungsgericht
geredet haben das ist ja die höchste ist
Instanz in keinem anderen Land geht das
im übrigen das Abgeordnete als Richter
in das höchste Gericht hinein wechseln
können die vorher über die Gesetze
entschieden haben sie teilweise gemacht
haben wir haben ein ganz klaren
Interessenkonflikt über ihren harbart
und die ganzen Abgeordneten die er
plötzlich jetzt Richter weil ich muss
leider das ist ja auch schon vorher so
ich muss leider eine kurze Unterbrechung
aber die Zahlen